c'est une image fascinante digne d'un
film de science-fiction une boule de feu
qui traverse le ciel avant de se
désintégrer dans l'atmosphère il est 4h
du matin et en Angleterre en Belgique
mais aussi en France plusieurs témoins
filment le passage de cet astéroïde d'un
mètre de diamètre observez à Paris au
Havre c'est au-dessus de roues qu'il
était le plus visible mais que s'est-il
passé au-dessus de nos têtes ces
derniers jours un objet non identifié
est entré illégalement dans l'espace
aérien du Canada
après le mystérieux ballon espion
chinois de nouveaux objets volants non
identifiants survolé le ciel
nord-américain créant ainsi des
anomalies radars et perturbant l'espace
aérien au total ce sont pas moins de 4
ovnis de forme et de taille différente
qui ont été aperçus en 10 jours et qui
inquiète les autorités
[Musique]
[Rires]
vous avez vu un truc
oui rire
confirmation en lévitation combinaison
rouge moulante ventre rebondi c'était à
la mi-temps du Super Bowl bien sûr le
chaud que l'on attendait vous avez un
petit crash pour Ryana c'est faux
regardez-moi dans les yeux d'abord pour
mon épouse et oui d'accord mais vous
avez un petit crush pour Rihanna ou pas
je suis une artiste que j'apprécie
beaucoup
il faut parfois il faut dire les choses
porter la pub dans la plaie c'est notre
métier elle est belle on adore 34 ans la
pêche on a le résultat du match
oui c'est quand ça City qui a gagné
c'est pas évident
la pub pour le forfait 5ject à immonde
la tenue de Rihanna immonde la musique
de Rihanna abomino
les gens prennent pas des
entitéspresseurs derrière si on a celui
la prestation des interprètes en langue
des signes au moment des conférences de
presse covid en France regardez salut en
engagement de Justin miles les
Américains qui traduisent en même temps
le show de la mi-temps les paroles mais
aussi les intentions de la chanteuse
franchement sacrée performance là aussi
elle a dû avoir des sacrés courbatures
ce matin bravo à elle je suis fan on se
retrouve là tous les deux
émissions ensemble bon on était un peu
ennemis mais ça va là vu qu'on est
équipé ça peut que fonctionner par
contre pour la commande du beau gosse on
repassera j'ai demandé une belle pomme
je me retrouve avec un raisin sec dans
un geste d'une élégance rare je rectifie
mes cheveux pour ne pas gêner la
production je joue vous êtes trop sexy
je crois que tu as raison baby
[Musique]
aura des pâquerettes tous
vous pensez à quelle pâquerette
un an je passe on se dit qui vous
apprendra plus rien le derrière qu'on a
plus une minute à perdre à son sujet
puis on recommence encore une fois
cependant rien que pour en avoir le cœur
net qu'il est bien vide et on apprend
tout de même quelque chose de neuf à son
égard ça suffit à vous remettre en train
d'optimisme on se remet à penser on se
remet hespérez alors qu'on espérait plus
du tout alors fatalement on y retourne
au derrière pour le même prix
78% des personnes qui marchent au fond
de la randonnée régulièrement déclaré
cela avait amélioré leur vie sexuelle
donc le jogging arrive sur la deuxième
marche du podium
on a rendez-vous avec une attaché de
presse de la SNCF qui doit nous
accompagner pendant le tournage mais
elle vient de nous envoyer un texto
bonjour je risque d'avoir du retard car
mon train initial a été supprimé ça
s'invente pas
la tâche est de presse ne vient pas pour
répondre à nos questions mais pour
garder un oeil sur notre tournage
bonjour
enchanté pourquoi vous êtes en retard du
coup
a déclaré que le yoga avait amélioré ses
capacités sexuelles aussi
c'est bon
à poil oui c'est vrai donc c'est vrai
j'ai vu ça
tout à fait tout à fait nu en fait
et pourquoi parce que d'une part ça
évite les frottements de vous connaissez
quoi pour les bruits et au-delà de ça
c'est la liberté du mouvement on fait ce
qu'on veut
de février de l'an 2023 je me suis
retrouvé ça peut vous arriver dans une
émission de radio et de télé où l'on
essaye de résoudre votre problème
mettre son smartphone dans du riz s'il
est tombé dans l'eau la technique est
déconseillée mais peut parfois
fonctionner en revanche personne n'a
essayé avec une voiture électrique
jusqu'à ses youtubeurs américains qui
ont utilisé près de deux tonnes de pour
ensevelir ce véhicule à l'arrêt après
avoir été inondé lors d'un ouragan trois
jours plus tard à en croire ses
messieurs toute l'humidité a été
absorbée et le moteur redémarre
infiniment merci à vous tous qui êtes
ici et que mon problème devienne
l'histoire ancienne
à partir d'aujourd'hui nous allons
exiger de tout ce qui viennent